I only got one life this is not a dress
rehearsal can I remind you of that you
don't get a chance to do this life over
again this is the show I don't buy into
this this idea that you have to
compromise who you are
compromise what you believe as a matter
of fact be even more bold at who you are
more bold of who you believe because you
are the hero of your own story do you
realize that procrastination is like
playing Russian roulette with your
destiny you think you have more time
than you do so you go ahead and delay
what's supposed to be done today to a
time that may never materialize
what's that believed nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you explode out into the world to have a
big impact for you your family and the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn from producer
author and creature Devon Franklin and
my take on his top ten rules for success
rule number three is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always
guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below and put quotes around
that so other people can be inspired and
when you write it down it's much more
likely to stick for yourself as well
enjoy
I hold in my hand chocolate chips
chocolate chip cookies right now what's
interesting is this is just an example
of when you go to any supermarket
there is a whole aisle dedicated to
chocolate chip cookies you can get
whatever flavor or everstyle you want
but what dawned on me is that you mean
to tell me there's a whole aisle of the
same product so as I I sat there looking
at the aisle I said how is it possible
in almost every supermarket in the
country
there can be an aisle dedicated to the
same product as I began to think about
it I said it might be the same chocolate
chip but what differentiates one brand
from another the recipe may I submit for
your consideration these chocolate chip
cookies represent success we all have
been destined to be successful but each
one of us has a different recipe that
God will use to create success what I
know is that Keebler ain't trying to
steal mrs. Fields recipe because Keebler
does what they do mrs. Fields do what
they do and they both can sell millions
of cookies every single year why cuz
they're committed to their recipe they
believe that their recipe is the best
and as a result they still find success
you don't see on the package of mrs.
field we taste just like a blurs now
mrs. fields as mrs. fields
Keibler dismisses caylor's and Chips
Ahoy is Chips Ahoy oh your difference is
your destiny you have a recipe for your
success so why are you over there trying
to steal your neighbor's recipe why
don't you start cooking up what God gave
you start mixing up your ingredients and
know that if your neighbor can find
space on the Isle of the world for
success that God has some shelf space
for you too
I only got one life this is not a dress
rehearsal can I remind you of that you
don't get a chance to do this life over
again this is the show you're waiting to
perform the performance is now so if you
don't live out your truth if you don't
embrace your difference will you be able
to look back and say whatever you
shortchanged your difference for it was
worth it whoever you shortchange your
difference for were they worth it
so often we become a limited version of
ourselves just to be accepted by
somebody who then goes on to move on to
somebody else and there we are left with
the damage of having compromised
ourselves for their love and acceptance
and they decide no no and they're on to
somebody else and we're still left
healing from a situation we should have
never been in to begin with say your
notes Devon I just need to tell you
right now please do not want love so
badly you compromised who you are to get
it if somebody you're dating cannot
handle the fullness of your purpose and
your calling and your personality why
don't you go ahead and drop them right
now please drop them cut it off let it
off why because all you're doing is
wasting your time and there
I'm who you're created to be and if they
cannot handle that god bless them go
ahead and buy my bag of cookies and say
I'll see you on the other side but I
cannot allow myself to be subject to
your limited thinking I am bigger than
your capacity to handle Who I am Who am
I talking to right now
your difference is your destiny and so
here I am an 18 year old you know young
man got into the University of Southern
California I go in for my first
internship interview at the management
company that manages Will Smith I'm
literally about to get my foot in the
door and at the end of the interview the
lady says Devon is there anything else
you want us to know and right there God
is speaking in my ear he said tell her
about the Sabbath now you must
understand something as a Christian I
grew up observing Sabbath so Friday
night sundown Saturday night sundown I
don't work it's the day that I take off
for observance rest and restoration and
I'm there in the internship interview
about to get my door foot in the door of
Hollywood and God says tell her about
the Sabbath I said Lord after I get the
internship I'll tell her all about the
Sabbath you know how we are we love to
get what we want and then we'll start
moving the pieces around about what we
can and cannot do but after a moment of
silence I said well I cannot take this
internship if it requires me to work on
the Sabbath and it was quiet just like
it is now and after a moment of silence
she said Devon don't worry we can work
around that what that taught me in that
moment is that it's not about just the
door of opportunity opening in your
scene it's about how you walk through
the door because every door that opens
that does not allow you to fit your
faith and who you are I argue it is not
a door to go through you have to
understand that when you are walking in
your path and you are walking in the
movie of your life the scenes in your
life will conform around you if you have
enough faith to be exactly who God
created you to be
I don't buy into this this idea that you
have to compromise who you are
compromise what you believe as a matter
of fact be even more bold in who you are
more bold and who you believe because
you are the hero of your own story and
if you don't believe your story guess
what
ain't nobody else going to what would
you say is the biggest lesson you
learned from that intern experience
those four years you know it's something
that I
I knew already you know again growing up
in the church one of the things that
that was instilled in us my uncle as a
pastor was all about service all about
service I mean we would going to the
community we pass out food we pass out
flyers you know we would get to the
church at you know eight o'clock on
sabbath morning and not leave till eight
o'clock at night so getting to being in
turn that training and service was the
key to my success because as an intern
you know no one came to me every day and
said here's your assignment i had to go
find work to do i had to go you know say
hey can i fax that for you can i file
that for you and remember coffee orders
you know go get dry cleaning but also do
it with excellence do it like it was
important because sometimes those tasks
we don't want we want the office we want
the job you know we want the title we
want the money we don't want to do the
entry-level stuff and sometimes you know
people that i've even hired and interns
that I've worked with they don't have
any excellence in that work because they
think it's a bear above it but when you
put excellence on that and you serve it
said and you say hey this is as
important as the job I want people see
that so for me it was applying the
service how can I make everyone's job
here better and not just the principles
but the assistants as well you know the
support staff because if you don't have
relation with the support staff you're
not having a relation with the
principles and so that was my my one
lesson that I really learned that's that
service is King and that service is the
key to your ascension and and and I can
tell you that that lesson just keeps
replaying itself at every level just a
different way people don't believe that
they're good enough yeah they don't
believe they have what it takes but when
you embrace who you are and not worry
about fitting in anybody's by yeah well
you know if they don't believe they have
what it takes I think a lot of people
don't believe they have what it takes
cuz they're comparing themselves yes
everybody else instead of looking at
themselves I say oh people stay in your
own movie
we're over here looking at other
people's movie yeah yeah and you have no
idea you look at someone else's movie
and in one scene it looks like they're
on the top well yeah yeah you have no
idea what's gonna really happen in that
next scene yeah so you stay in your
movie you focus on your scene you become
the best that you can be yeah
you'll be surprised at how great your
own story works yeah continue to refine
I develop your own script absolutely and
and and your own fire I'm gonna start
using them that's right be very careful
then how you live not as unwise but as
wise making the most of every
opportunity and there are some
translations that say making the most of
your time because the days are evil so
let me submit for your consideration
that when we were born we both were
given two things talent and time talent
and time talent and time turn to your
neighbor on your right and say you got
some talent turn to your neighbor on the
left but say do you have the time oh I
want to talk to somebody right now
because see one of these two things is a
limited resource the other is an
unlimited resource your talent is
unlimited I need you to know this that
what you have within you what God put
within you is unlimited all right the
people you think see here's the thing
some of you think that people have
stolen things from you and kept
opportunities from you let me tell you
something that God has more than what
they tried to take from you because
there's more talent in you than they
even realized they think they stole one
idea but you got a million more they
think they took what was from you but
God said what I put in you can create
again so don't worry about not having
enough talent you got that but the
limited resource is the time mmm I wish
I could tell you you had more time than
you do this is why God wanted me to come
here today and hopefully inspire and
motivate you to reclaim your time
reclaim that which is yours to begin
with at the end of your life at the end
of my life God is going to ask me what
did you do with the time that I gave you
i'ma come sit next to watch this watch
this so often
[Music]
can't even get through my message
[Music]
because there's something I know I have
not done and God in His grace and His
mercy keeps sending an alarm in our
spirit saying my son and my daughter I
need you to be obedient I need you to
get it right in this season I need you
to stop procrastinating in this season
and so the alarm keeps going off and
some of us because we're not ready we
say oh I'll answer this I'll answer
tomorrow do you realize that
procrastination it's like playing
Russian roulette with your destiny you
think you have more time than you do so
you go ahead and delay what's supposed
to be done today to a time that may
never materialize and then we wonder why
we're not happy because we're not
productive in doing what he called us to
do I don't know who I'm talking to right
now but God said it is time to reclaim
your time we all have the same amount of
time in the day now how much time do we
have in this life I don't know I don't
know I don't know how much time you have
left I don't know how much time I got
left but guess what I don't worry about
what I don't know I worry about what I
do know he woke me up this morning he
started me on this way and if he woke me
up that means he financed my gift for
today so I better get busy turns here
never say you better get busy you better
get busy you better get busy I'm growing
up in a Christian home in a Christian
environment I had this dream that maybe
one day I could go to Hollywood and in
work and entertainment now that was not
a very faith friendly dream because
Hollywood still is today by many people
viewed as as Sodom and Gomorrah as the
devil's playground
many people said well if you want you
know to live out your faith Devon don't
go to Hollywood don't do it you're gonna
lose your faith it's it's gonna corrupt
you there's no way you can be about God
and be in that industry and so here I
was as a young person having a dream a
vision a call from
but having the conflict that those that
around me don't see the call the way
that I see it so I had a choice do I
stay within the lane that they have
ordained or do I have enough faith to go
after the lane that God had ordained and
that was a leap and that was a challenge
and that was a conflict that I think all
of us face what you say in the book is
that development begins when you have
the first vision of what you can be
correctly you can't write a movie unless
you know what the movie's supposed to be
about
that's what development is sometimes we
get so frustrated in our lives but we
have to go back and say wait a minute do
I understand what the big idea of my
life is supposed to be if my life is a
story then I have to know the point of
my story and sometimes what happens when
we start developing a movie
the producers may have one vision of
what the movies supposed to be and the
studio has another version and then the
movie becomes nothing because there's
not clarity of idea so with our life we
have to have clarity of what we're
supposed to do what do we believe were
called to do in this life and in that
way it gives our whole development
process more shape
my mother was mother was still is a
disciplinarian then she you know from we
were young I mean from three and four
years old I mean having to do chores and
vacuum and wash dishes and take out the
trash and keep our room clean and and
all of those things that at the time I
hate it I value so much now because they
gave me a foundation that really helped
me navigate organize lead manage so you
know that discipline was something that
she really instilled in us and I think a
lot of the success I've been able to
have comes from her and her you know
saying look I'm not gonna let you guys
just go and be wild that is how boys do
it as a studio executive one of the
things I do is I develop scripts into
movies but there are some scripts that
we develop for a very long time and it
never looks like it's going to get made
and we call this period of time
development hell some of you have been
in development hell because you had an
idea for your life and you've been
trying and you've been pushing to allow
that idea to get into production but you
see
so far away from it that you don't know
what you're gonna do and in this moment
in development hell it is so tempting to
give up on the very idea that brought
you this far you must realize that in
development hell when you're going
through a time where you're about to
give up on yourself give up on your God
give up on your friends give up on your
dreams and your beliefs this is the time
when you have to go back to the original
idea that motivated your life and hold
on to it and don't give up because you
know why because it is just like a scene
of a movie there are some good scenes
there are some bad scenes but if you
keep walking forward guess what the hero
always wins and you know what makes the
story good the conflict the hero faces
so when you go through bad scenes that
must mean you are getting ready to be
prepared to be victorious you must know
that a bad scene with conflict is not
meant to take you down but it's meant to
actually bring out the hero in you and
build you up so how do you define
success you have to define success one I
define success as peace mmm do you like
meat there's nothing without that No
okay go I'll let you finish oh you who
looks back at you in the mirror do you
like that person are you at peace for
you that peace with that person are you
content yeah that is the foundation of
success you can be the most famous
person in the world yeah and not have
peace and I already know as you have
never we do yeah we do and I would argue
you're not successful you know we cannot
allow external forces just tell us we
are success yeah you are fulfilled by
what you do yeah you are fulfilled when
you get up in the morning you know so
many times we up in the morning we're
depressed we're down we're angry were
frustrated oh you can wake up saying I'm
glad to be a lot there is purpose of
this day to me that is success and I
would argue that once you have that
internal success yeah then externally
it's just a manifestation of what
happens internally in the best possible
way
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because cephus asked me
to if there's something you'd like me to
cover in a future top 10 check out the
link in the description and go and cast
your vote I'd also love to know what did
you learn from this video what lesson
really hit home the hardest what are you
going to immediately apply somehow to
your life or to your business leave it
down the comments below I'm really
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to Devon Trish Devon
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word posting it to
your Instagram account
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you soon
you know the biggest lesson I learned
from my father was to be to not accept
[Music]
substance I don't want to say abuse but
don't accept you know what do you call
it
digesting or ingesting so don't don't
because some part of culture is that you
know the substances whether it be
alcohol whether it be cigarettes drugs
or whatever well that's just a part of
the culture right I mean you know what's
big what what differs does it make if
you drink that's just part of culture if
you don't drink then you're weird so
when I learned from him is that you know
as someone who did drink and for someone
who drank he did drink he did and he was
an alcoholic my entire life which
contributed to his early demise and so
what I learned from him was like don't
just buy into the status quo you have to
find what works for you
mmm and there was a lot of pressure he
felt in his job and didn't realize you
know the severity of what alcoholism
would do to him and you know he was
doing it and didn't you know thought oh
it's just me just doing what everybody
else does and everybody else goes out to
drink after work and that's what I do
and didn't realize that was setting him
up for some very tragic events so I
really learned from that experience and
otha to to not not go with the flow just
because that's where the flow was going
have a point of view that's right and
others don't I know what works for you
yeah it works for me so there I was
having to make a decision am I going to
go to Hollywood am I going to try to
live out my faith but still be adherent
to what I believed as a Christian and I
had to challenge those that came at me
and they said I said you know if you
don't actually have experience with
Hollywood if you haven't actually worked
a day in Hollywood so you mean to tell
me you're using your perception of what
you think it is based upon a secondhand
knowledge of it not a first-hand
experience and then you're trying to
dictate the destiny on my life based
upon what you haven't experienced
yourself I appreciate that you love me
but lovely enough to teach me how to use
my fate in the most treacherous waters
don't love me so much where you want to
keep me close to the shore because I
don't care where you live the shore gets
the waves of life - so teach me how to
use my faith when life gets rough so I
had to go I had to see I had to explore
I watched these movies like rocky and
back to the future you know what I loved
about Rocky is is rocky said listen he
thought he was a bomb and when he got
the chance to fight Apollo Creed what
was his number one goal he said I don't
even care if I win I just want to go the
distance and when I would see movies
like that as a kid I said that's me you
know as a middle child any middle
children in the house okay we were
having a support group after this all
right you know we need a little extra
care and counseling because the older
one my older brother was he was the
oldest and my youngest was was the baby
and Here I am the middle child kind of
put off to the side but when I would see
films I would get inspired and I said I
want to be able to make movies that can
absolutely touch people in the way that
Rocky and the color purple and and back
to the future did for me the most
important word ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]